got it and so that's a very unique way
of viewing the world
right um kind of talk through uh
how you think about it from you have
seen money to live
right yeah there's a story recently uh
there was a
i think a multi-billionaire uh who
basically had amassed a fortune of like
eight billion dollars uh and he has now
successfully given it all away he
literally lives in like a
shoebox san francisco apartment says
that he's incredibly happy
uh and his entire life goal was to give
away his fortune um and he's now done
that
uh but he amassed a fortune and then
gave it away
are you kind of as you're making money
giving it away or is this uh let's get
as much money as possible it's a good
question
and i sort of think if you can do it the
ideal thing
in some ways there's a lot of activity
about this is sort of the
actual answer and here are two ways to
think about it right one is like
well if you amass money you can grow
that money
you know and like then you can give away
way more than if you've been giving away
the whole time
because you know you get interest on
that money one way or another
the other way of thinking about it is
sure well also the charities could have
been doing things with that in the
meantime
and you know they could have been saving
people's lives who have been
contributing to the world
and like doesn't that have some
compounding effects too
and sort of the answer is yeah actually
most things that are really high impact
have compounding effects
the compounding serve part of what makes
some high impact and you have to sort of
think about which is bigger
and so i think you know part of how i
think about is like given where i
am right now you know what's what's sort
of relatively larger
and i mean i think for people who are in
crypto right now it's not going to shock
them to hear
that like returns on capital can be
pretty significant
and and and and you know i think that
you just have to look like what's
happened in d5
over the last you know four months to
see that like
that's going to outstrip a lot of things
um and so part of my answer is like well
if you think you have unusually way you
know unusually good ways to grow money
which you
probably do if you're in the business of
growing money
uh then that's like a decent argument
towards towards sort of growing it over
time and
then donate on the other hand and these
a lot of people would say this and they
think they have a real point
like yeah sure i've heard that one
before you know like like
person says oh yeah don't worry like
this is you know i'm one of the good
guys
um and and i think that that's like
you know that's a real word that you can
have about other people and it's where
you can have about yourself
even if you're not you know even if
you're not selfish it's a sort of
drifting way
forgetting about why you got there in
the first place
and so what i actually do and i'm not
saying this is a perfect thing like
there's
things pulling in all directions here
but you know i sort of
give away enough each year that it's
sort of a real amount
that's a significant amount and that it
sort of keeps me honest
and and you know keeps me i i
yeah sort of he keeps me um
keeps reminding me of like why i did
this in the first place
keeps me in touch with people who are
thinking about it keeps me in the loop
about things
i can do keeps me thinking about what i
can do with money
and and so even if it's not like most of
my money each year even if a lot of it
is you know the goal is to compound it
and give it later um
i there's a lot of good that that i
think you can
there's a lot of good you can do now and
i think that there's a lot of value to
at least giving something away to keep
yourself honest
absolutely and so let's talk about what
you've done to
uh grow wealth right so you've got kind
of two separate things you've got ftx
and then you've got alabita research
uh jane street is a pretty legit shop
right that's a pretty good job
when you decided to leave did you know
that you were going to go
uh into crypto or was this more of you
left and then as you were exploring
things to do crypto kind of caught your
eye
yeah like when i left there were like 12
things i i sort of didn't know exactly
what i
can do and actually i was like going to
try working at a charity was one of one
of the things that added an effective
altruistic and
and i think that like sort of there are
all these paths and they're so hard to
think about right like
you know here's one thing that like you
know and there's so many things you
think about you're like oh
boy who the hell knows how valuable that
is you know like you
campaign for policies that you think are
good or for
politicians you think will implement
them or you could go work on climate
change you go work on third world
developing diseases some of these turn
out to be
somewhat analyzable like you can look at
sort of a classic example as like how
many lives
per dollar can you save donating to
third world health charities
and you can actually ballpark that right
you can just do trials right you can go
into a village you can give malaria
treat bed nets um and and see what
happens the malaria rates and there's a
lot of complications but like
you know that's sort of an inanalyzable
thing but many of these things are
really hard
to ballpark you know if you're gonna
like how much impact can you have on the
world as a journalist the answer has to
be a lot
like clearly they have impact on the
world but it's really hard to think
about
how much and what the right thing to do
is so sort of my thought was like
boy there are all these things i want to
try doing some of them i can sort of
think about some of them have a lot of
trouble estimating
and just gonna be hard to know how big
they could get until i try
and and so that was sort of the thought
was try a bunch of things and like
see what sticks